نتحدث ايضا عن استهداف مروحيه اسرائيليه
بصاروخ ارض جو ونحن في اليوم المئه لهذه
الحرب كيف تنظر الى اولا وجود هذه الشبكات
في كل مساحه قطاع غزه وايضا مساله استهداف
مروحيه نعم تحيه لك ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
نعم لا شك بان طبيعه المعركه او طبيعه
القتال في المناطق المبنيه تفرض مثل هذه
التكتيكات التي تجري الان على الارض
فعندما تحاول قوات الاحتلال التقدم من
محاور مختلفه باتجاه مناطق معينه او اهداف
معينه لا شك بانها تصطدم بمقاومه من قبل
فصائل المدافعه في هذه المناطق وبالتالي
نرى بمثل هذه العمليات التي تتراوح ما بين
القصف بالهوان او ما بين نصب الكمائن او
ما بين استخدام السلاح المدرع او استخدام
السلاح ضد الاشخاص
وبالتالي ل انواع متعدده من التكتيكات
التي يمكن ان تستخدم من قبل فصائل
المقاومه لايقاف تقدم الجيش المتقدم
باتجاه اهدافه في هذه المناطق ولكن بشكل
عام عندما نتكلم عن الشمال نتكلم عن جيوب
لازالت متواجده في هذه المناطق تستطيع ان
تقوم بعمليات ضد القطعات التي تحاول
التطهير في هذه المنطقه بشكل كامل لمعرفه
اماكن الانفاق ومعرفه اماكن مخازن الاسلحه
او القيادات التي لازالت متواجده في
القطاع الشمالي يضاف الى ذلك بان القطاع
الاوسط والقطاع الجنوبي لم تستطع القوات
الصهيونيه رغم المعارك التي تجري السيطره
على هذه المناطق او التوغل بها كما كان
سابقا في المنطقه الشماليه لذلك العمليات
التي تجري الان تجري بحذر تام من قبل
القوات المتقدمه يضاف الى هذا بانه
الانفاق الان تعيق عمل القطاعات المتقدمه
بشكل كبير جدا والدليل على هذا بانه
الكمائن التي ظهرت في الفتره الماضيه او
التخريبات التي وضعت في مداخل هذه الانفاق
تعطي دلاله واضحه على ان هناك معركه
دفاعيه تديرها فصائل المقاومه من خلال
استخدام التكتيكات فوق الارض وتحت الارض
من خلال الانفاق
ل يعني المعركه الاساسيه الان هي على خان
يونس لماذا تشتبك المقاومه في الشمال يعني
لماذا لا
توفر نريد ان نفهم يعني لماذا لا توفر
طاقتها لمعركه خان يونس لماذا تشتبك في
الشمال
ايضا
نعم هذه القضيه تتعلق بالخطه الدفاعيه
التي وضعت عندما وضعت الخطه الدفاعيه من
قبل فصائل المقاومه وضعت بان كل منطقه
لديها لواء ولديها كتائب من خلال هذا
اللواء تدير عمليتها الدفاعيه بمعزل عن
القطاعات الاخرى المتواجده في بقيه القطاع
لذلك نرى بان العمليات لم تتوقف في الشمال
ابدا وانما استمرت طوال الفتره الماضيه
وهي ستستمر خلال الفتره المقبله ايضا لانه
لا لا تزال هناك كتائب تعمل ولا تزال هناك
امكانيات وقدرات على استمرار هذه العمليات
اما في القطاع الجنوبي القطاع الجنوبي
عندما تصطدم المحاور المتقدمه بمقاومه
شرسه وضاره تتوقف هذه الارتال ويحاول
القائد ان يحاول ان يجد محاور اخرى للتقدم
ع في مناطق عسى ان تكون ضعيفه يمكن الذ
اليه خلالها باتجاه الاهداف المرسومه التي
خففت فيها اسرائيل من وجودها و على قل
انسحبت وفق
قراءات انسحبت منها واعتبرتها مناطق ربما
تمت السيطره عليها معنى ان يكون هنالك
اشتباك في هذه
المناطق الا يطرح ذلك تساؤلات كبيره حول
ما
حققه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في اي منطقه
دخلها وخرج
منها نعم لا شك بانه عندما عندما توغل في
الم المنطقه الشماليه قلنا بان التوغل لا
تعني السيطره الميدانيه على هذه المنطقه
خصوصا وان الحرب لا تجري على سطح الارض
فقط وانما تجري من خلال انفاق هذه الانفاق
تنتشر بشكل كبير جدا وتؤدي الى مناطق
متعدده والمدافع يعرف كيف يوظف هذه
الانفاق بالطريقه التي يراها مناسبه بحيث
يمكن ايقاع الخسائر بالقطاعات المتواجده
في هذه المناطق على الرغم من الانسحاب من
الشمال ولكنه انسحب الى مناطق معينه لا
زالت القطعات متواجده قطعات الجيش
الصهيوني متواجده في القطاع الشمالي
ولكنها انسحبت الى الاطراف وبالتالي هي
تقوم بعمليات تمشيط وتطهير لبعض المناطق
التي لم تتم فيها مثل هذه العمليات ومع
هذا توجد بعض الجيوب المتواجده في هذه
المناطق تقوم بهذه العمليات على القطاعات
المتقدمه
لذ الم المبنيه لن تنتهي بهذه السهوله نعم
عقيد حاتم فيما يتعلق باسقاط المروحيه
يعني اريد ان اسالك عن هذه عن عن مساله
المروحيه بصاروخ ارض جو طبعا استخدمت
صواريخ ارد جو من قب قبل ا لكن هو ليس
اسقاط خلينا نقول استهداف لانه هذا ما
يقاله بالتحديد بيان القسام ا ايضا هنالك
فيديو لجيش الاحتلال يستهدف كما قال منصات
اطلاق الصواريخ وشاهدنا صاروخ يخرج من
الارض وسط دخان ثم يسقط ا طبعا انا لا
يعني لا ازعم اني اتابع كل د تفصيلا من
تفاصيل الحرب لكن هذه اول مره يعلنون فيها
استهداف منصات صواريخ بالفيديو ويصورونها
بالفيديو هكذا ام ام حدث هذا من
قبل نعم سابقا لم تظهر مثل هذه مثل هذه
التصاوير التي تتكلم عنها الان في مساله
معالجه منصه صواريخ هنا او هناك ولكن لا
شك بانه يمكن ان يتوصل الى هذه المنصات
يعني ولكن السؤال هل هي هذه المنصات تمثل
جميع المنصات التي تتواجد فصائل للمقاومه
ام انها منصه في منطقه جغرافيه محدده وتم
تدميرها وقد تكون هذه المنصه تم الاستيلاء
عليها وقامت الطائرات بمثل هذه العمليه
وتم تصويرها على انها انجاز بالنسبه للجيش
الصهيوني الذي يعالج مساله اطلاق الصواريخ
ولكن هذه القضيه يمكن ان تكون حقيقيه
عندما نرى فصائل المقاومه هل ستستمر
باطلاق هذه الصواريخ ام انها ستتوقف عندئذ
يمكن ان نقول بانه تم ايقاف عمليه اطلاق
الصواريخ من مدينه غزه يضاف الى هذا بان
استهداف المروحيه طائرات الاباتشي او
غيرها بصواريخ من قبل المقاومه سبق وان
استخدمت سام 18 وهذا الصاروخ يطلق من
الكتف ويعالج اهداف تصل الى تقريبا المدى
مالها 5200 200 متر